the execution of the pirate king Goldie
Roger and the execution of his son
portcus D Ace One happens right at the
beginning of the story sparking the
great pirate era the other right in the
middle plunging the world into an era of
chaos and War so wouldn't it make sense
if there was one final execution that
would ring in an era of freedom and
peace for the entire world near the end
of one piece as well and at this point
in the story there's really only one
person that the government is as
desperate to execute as the first pirate
king which leaves us with a super
intriguing question what would happen if
Monkey D Luffy was about to be executed
by the Marines who would come to his
rescue and what would this second
version of marine Ford look like okay
imagine this it is sometime after Luffy
has just defeated kaido he has
officially been labeled a yonko and has
awakened his legendary devil fruits so
you might be wondering how would the
world government ever capture in the
first place well there are a few options
of how this could happen he could be
betrayed by one of his allies or even be
blackmailed if one of his friends had
been kidnapped but for the sake of this
video Let's just assume that someone has
drugged his pile of meat which knocks
Luffy out cold and he's then carried
away during the night and onto a
government ship next they slap on their
strongest sea prison stone that they
have submerge Luffy to the neck in a
tank of water tie him down with chains
and keep him guarded by an admiral and a
seraphim certainly this should be enough
to keep any devil fruit user contains
and now that Luffy's captured we have to
ask why would the government want to
execute Luffy in the first place well to
start he has already publicly declared
war on the world government he assaulted
a world Noble he is the son of dragon
the most wanted man in the world and he
is a yonko with a 3 billion Berry bouncy
on top of all that executing Luffy would
be a symbol to the world that the
government still owns the Seas just like
they did with Roger and Aces execution
and if all that isn't enough still they
would definitely want to eliminate the
awakened Nika user because of his ties
to Joy boy and the void Century so
really to sum it up Luffy is the single
biggest current threat to the world
government and their control of the
entire world okay and so now with Luffy
on a ship heading to new Marine Ford way
they plan to carry out this execution
the world government announces to the
worlds that Luffy will be put to death
in a few days time now you might be
wondering why the world government would
choose a public execution again after
they almost lost the war at Marine forts
well it's really quite simple you see a
public execution is about more than just
killing someone it is a symbol of power
and control and so by executing Luffy
with the whole world watching the world
government is sending a strong message
to all pirates that no matter how strong
you are the world's government cannot be
defeated as for why they chose new
Marine for it as the location here you
will see exactly why they chose this
spot in particular later on in the video
but first what about the other straw
hats oh why they're certainly strong at
this point they aren't powerful enough
to take on the entirety of the Marine
forces and rescue Luffy all by
themselves instead they immediately
tried to contact as many of their
friends as possible and tell them that
Luffy needs their help and by friends I
mean all of their friends oh that is a
pretty impressive group to say the least
are the Marines seriously even going to
stand a chance against this well you see
the Marines have many impressive
Fighters themselves plus the new
seraphim who are Advanced clones of the
former Warlords that were introduced
right after wano and while most
characters can be clearly divided in
either allies or enemies there are many
out there that have uncertain loyalties
as well for example what would GARP do
if Luffy was about to be executed I mean
we already saw that he could barely
contain himself when Ace was killed so
would he really stand by and let his
last remaining grandson die or how about
Kobe smoker or even fujitora how will
they behave on the battlefield OMS
speaking of said battlefields here is
what what we know about new Marine forts
this space became the new headquarters
after old Marine Ford was destroyed
during the war it has this massive many
tiered Fortress surrounded by Rocky
lands there are also these huge
McDonald's shaped arches and a bridge
that possibly leads to the red line
Luffy's execution platform is right here
guarded by akinu GARP and sengoku and
most of the Marine forces are gonna be
spread out around the islands including
the seraphim and vice Admirals while the
Admirals themselves weighed right here
above the main gate and at the top of
the structure Kong makes his first real
appearance to oversee the entire battle
and so let's get to that battle it's a
few days after Luffy was captured and
with the world watching the Thousand
Sunny approaches new Marine forts the
straw hats and Sabo who they picked up
along the way are lined up at the front
of the ship determined to save Luffy but
they of course immediately fired upon by
every single cannon in the Fortress and
Zoro and Sanji leap up in protectorship
and in return for Frankie pyre's their
Cannon raid at the Admirals however just
like at marineford they easily blocked
that blast and before the sunny can even
land greenbull sends out a ton of vines
to trap the ship and even though they're
not weak to fire Sabo is still strong
enough to use his flame powers to burn
the Vines and those two begin to battle
as a result the straw hats can now
emerge from the ship and are immediately
met by S hog and S Flamingo zaro and
Sanji take on those seraphim while the
other straw hats begin to fight the vice
Admirals and set a theme as they make
their way towards Luffy but of course
remember that they are not gonna fight
alone here prior to the battle the straw
hats and the grand Fleet gather to make
a coordinated plan of attack and now
that the Thousand Sunny has landed the
Allied captains joined the battle as
well spreading out to take on the other
main forces of the Marines the Battle Is
Now fully on however the Marines seem to
have the upper hand right now cannons
rained down on the grand Fleet the
seraphim blast allies with lasers and
all that Luffy can do is child
encouragements and cursed the Marines
and with the Allies struggling to make
progress the Marines now spring their
very first trap Akino literally erupts
into these massive streams of magma and
the magma then lands in these three
lines around the island basically
separating fighters from each other and
here's of course well I have to add that
even though we don't know how each of
these fights would go exactly we can
reasonably guess how close characters
are roughly in strength so while it's
entirely possible that the Allies would
just be destroyed here we will assume
that they are strong enough to survive
for now and so now with the fighters
trapped between the magma and the
superheated air above it the Admiral
sleep down into each of the three
sectors and begin to lay ways to the
Allies Akino sees that greenbelt's plans
are actually no match for Sabo and he
swaps places with the forest logia user
instead green ball enters the sector
with Zorro Sanji and usop are fighting
s-hawk and as Flamingo and while zaro
and Sanji are right now occupied with
the Sarah theme usup is left to run for
his life from the it's pretty much like
he's reliving his worst nightmare on the
other side of the island fujitora seems
to be more concerned with saving lives
than he is with attacking Nami Frankie
and Chopper although these three do now
in exchange have to contend with s shark
and S Croc no easy feat although Frankie
has already fought against F shark's
swim swim during his Battle of chats
with xenure pain this leaves kizeru free
to zip around and unleash light Bombs
all around the battlefield so uh yeah
things aren't looking that great for the
straw hats but thankfully there are more
allies on the way of course suddenly a
massive blast breath shoots out of the
clouds destroying all of the Cannons on
one side of the Fortress it seems like
the pink Dragon Momo and kaido Sun slash
daughter were a little bit late to the
battle after picking up Marco the
Phoenix and while these three are
powerhouses by themselves it seems that
the samurai of wano have stayed home to
protect their Islands regardless Momo
continues to blast The Fortress until
kizaru comes to confront them and while
Momo is a large Target for the light
logo user Yamato and Marco do enough to
keep the Admirals at Bay while Momo
destroys all of the Cannons and while
all of this is going on Kong jumps down
next to Luffy who is cursing at his
grandfather to finally let him go
because he knows that the way things are
going his crew and his Fleet will all
not survive because while Zoro and Sanji
can fight on par with the seraphim the
other straw hats simply can't hold out
Forever Robin and Brooke continue to
fight the shadow powers of s Gekko while
jimbei combines his Fishman karate and
the nearby water to fight against a
snake while on the other side of the
island Nami Frankie and Chopper have to
fight gravity and the Superhuman
strength of s Croc and S shark in the
meantime the grand Fleet is fighting
with the vice Admirals Hina smoker
Bastille doberman and Lance and they
can't do much else to help anyone else
they're busy on their own and in fact
things are about to get much much worse
akinu momentarily overwhelms Saba with
his Superior area magma powers and
Luffy's brother is thrown near the sea
just like at Marine Fort jinbei steps up
to stop a kainu but he is no match for
the Admiral with jimbei distracted as
snake is free to hunt Robin the seraphim
brushes aside Rob and sprouted Limbs and
grabs the archaeologist by the throat
choking the life out of her Brooke tries
to save her but he is stopped by S Gekko
Robin even tries to enter her demon form
but as snake is just too strong for her
however suddenly one Marine can just no
longer just stand by and watch flying in
with a flash of pink hair Kobe punches a
snake sending her crashing to the rocks
and luckily our favorite archaeologist
is free meanwhile Kobe is literally
shaking unsure of what to do next
Furious Akainu comes for Kobe and the
pink-haired Marine this time refuses to
cower as he did at Marine forts however
as Akino reaches back his Fiery Fist he
is blasted by a huge gust of wins
everyone on this side of the island
stops stunned as they see Monkey D
dragon and the rest of the Revolutionary
Army Standing On Top of the bridge and
while we don't know exactly yet what
dragon's real powers are every time
we've seen it in the story so far there
is strange wind and weather so for now
let's just assume that he has some sort
of crazy wind powers either from a devil
fruit or an ancient weapon or maybe just
the most overpowered wind dial in
history because Dragon looks down on the
battlefield he sends another blast of
wind that almost topples a kind of this
gives Sabo enough time to get some
healing from The tontada Princess Mon
Cheri so he can get back up and resume
his fight with the fleet Admiral
meanwhile Dragon stares towards his son
Luffy for a long moment but instead of
coming to save him he turns around and
makes his way across the bridge towards
the red line and marijuana it seems that
Dragon sees this chaos as the
opportunity to fulfill his own plans of
taking down the celestial dragons
however he will not get there so easily
because this whole time the gurusai have
been watching the battle ready to
intervene if necessary and now they do
finally see a chance to end one of the
most dangerous threats to the world
government that they ever faced and that
they intend to make use of it now again
we don't really know the full power of
the godosei but for this video we're
going to assume that they have some
truly strong fighting capabilities and
so along with cp0 they begin their
battle with the Revolutionary Army
meanwhile up in the air kizaru is
finally getting the better of momo
Yamato and Marco Momo is badly burned
from multiple light blasts and Marco is
really struggling to keep up with the
light fruit user as well on the ground
the grand Fleet is start to being
overwhelmed by the sheer number of Vice
Admirals and Marines and while Sanji has
defeated as Flamingo with his super
speed and fiery kicks Zorro is still
locked in his battle with s haq and poor
USA meanwhile is just barely staying
Alive running for his life and trying to
snipe at greenball luckily the straw
Hat's most powerful allies are about to
arrive buggy the clown is ready to join
the battle and while it seems like buggy
got a bit lost on the way to new Marine
Fort he now stands at the front of his
massive ship giving a passionate speech
about how cross Guild have come to take
out submarines of their own this really
rolls up his men but while he's
distracted kizeru sends a laser shot
right towards the newly crowned yonko
unable to react in time buggy is Saved
By The Sword of his longtime friend
Shanks welcome to the party red hair
Pirates Shanks leaps onto the
battlefield followed by his Crazy Crew
Hancock Rayleigh as well as crocodile
and mihawk who have come together with
buggy or the other way around I guess
Shanks immediately heads towards the
bridge where the revolutionaries are
being overrun right now surely he is
going to help dragon against the godosei
right right well at the same time mihawk
begins to fight his clone which frees
Zorro to save usab from greenball
likewise crocodile takes on ass Croc
while Rayleigh and hackcock take over
fighting the seraphim attacking Robin
and Brooke now going back up to the
Fortress Luffy is thrilled to see so
many of his friends coming to help his
crew while GARP smolders watching the
battlefield below but it is at this
point where the tights seem to be
turning that Kong has seen enough and he
orders Luffy's immediate execution as
this announcement spreads across the
battlefield the straw hats become
frantic Sanji tries to come help but
Kizer who keeps him away Frankie
launches a laser beam but it is easily
blocked by as bear Zorro manages to
defeat green ball and leaps up to the
First wall but he is stopped by the
Golden Buddha sengoku and now that usop
is not running for his life he climbs a
rock and Snipes towards Kong however the
commander-in-chief easily takes usop
shot and doesn't even Flinch and now The
Executioner's blades begin to fall but
Shanks unleashes a conquerors hockey
blast that shakes the entire Islands
weak characters from both sides just
fall and collapse to the grounds and it
is more than enough to knock out the two
executioners who always seem seem to be
these like random dudes I mean why not
however Kong snatches one of their
blades and is about to bring it down on
Luffy's neck only that this time unlike
at Marine Ford carp is not just going to
stand by and watch GARP crushes the
blade in a hockey covered Fist and the
most epic Clash of Marines ever begins
and while we once again don't know how
strong exactly both Kong or Garb are
we're just going to assume that he
should be at least a match for Luffy's
grandfather both of these legendary
Marines start throwing Island shaking
punches crushing Stone beneath their
feet but eventually garp's intense
motivation to save his last remaining
grandson helps him win this brawl and he
throws Kong down to the foot of the
bridge now while all of this has been
happening Akainu has yet again
overwhelmed Sabo and Kobe this man is
just too strong also strangely the
gurosei and wounded Kong are rich
treating towards the red line leaving
zp0 to fight the revolutionaries now
this frees Shanks to confront Akainu and
the two begin the fight that we never
got to see at Marine forts on the other
side of the battlefield Momo and Yamato
have come to help fight fujitora but the
blight admiral has become even more
disinterested in fighting and is simply
looking up into the sky instead what
could he be sensing up there now with
Kong defeated Luffy yells for his
grandpa to finally set him free but
instead Garb starts lecturing Luffy
about his bad choice to become a pirate
and how he's put all of his friends and
allies at risk here after voicing his
frustration GARP reaches down to unlock
the sea prison Stone chains however as
he does blood spurts from his mouth and
a Sinister laugh Echoes throughout the
battlefield Luffy shouts in shock as his
grandfather topples over and suddenly
three men become visible besides the
execution platform they are shiryu with
his invisibility powers and his blade
dripping Bloods then auger who has the
teleportation devil fruit and of course
blackbeards GARP coughs blood again and
tries to rise but it's too late before
the vice admiral can stand Blackbeard
takes his pistol and shoots him in the
back over and over again and this
happens right in front of Luffy until
garp's eyes close and he lays still
Luffy's eyes waver his hair flashes
white conquerors hockey shoots from him
like lightning and the walls tremble
suddenly a golden fist descends on the
four Pirates as single cool Roars with
rage Blackbeard blocks sengoku's giant
punch and with his other hand sends out
shock waves that make the former Fleet
Admiral fall to the ground Zorro also
leaps up and clashes with shiryu but
when auger teleports the three of them
to the other side of the battlefield
leaving Blackbeard and Luffy alone and
then shouts rise from the battlefield as
all eyes are starting to lock on the two
pirate king rivals Blackbeard's Darkness
covered fist reaches down and grabs
Luffy by the neck Luffy thrashes trying
to break free but it is impossible to do
Blackbeard's fruit and the Sea Stone
still weakening him Blackbeard takes his
pistol points it at Luffy's head but
before he can pull the trigger the sky
suddenly darkens Blackbeard stops and
looks up as does everyone else dark
clouds have gathered and above them
there is some incredible mass of light
now with everyone distracted God Usopp
takes advantage of this moment you see
the Waxman Mr 3 has also arrived
together with the cross guilds and just
like at Marine Fort he makes a key to
unlock the sea prison Stone handcuffs as
well Usopp Snipes the key all the way
across the battlefields perfectly into
the slot on Luffy's handcuffs as he's
held up by blackbeards and Luffy is free
just in time for beams of light to rain
down from the sky you see this was part
of the plan all along in a situation
like this it would be the perfect moment
for the gorosei or emu to use their
super power weapon capable of destroying
whole islands and the reason that they
wanted this execution out in the open
just like at Marine Fort was to gather
all the strongest pirates of the world
and wipe all of them out with one felt
swoop even if they killed many many of
the Marines in the process they now
effectively started the great cleansing
that they mentioned all the way back in
chapter 908 and at this point there are
many many ways such an event could
possibly go the lasers could certainly
be strong enough to kill everyone
gathered at new Marine forts but for
this video we're going to assume that
there is a way to survive enter our
enraged Sun Gods Luffy now fully in his
awakened form Luffy grabs part of the
Fortress walls and stretches it out
across the sky above the island just as
the lasers come raining down the wall
gets obliterated but it just manages to
stop the lasers Rubble starts falling
everywhere destroying the island and
many of the pirate ship waiting in the
ocean even the massive arches of the new
marineford building begin to crash to
the ground it is pure chaos until
suddenly the stone start freezing in the
air you see Fuji Torah has now fully
abandoned the fight and is using his
full gravity powers to try and stop the
falling stones and at this point
survival is everything that's on
everyone's Minds can you imagine seeing
such destructive Powers nearly wiping
everyone else I mean who wouldn't want
to run from this members of the grand
Fleet return to the ships that are still
intact as fast as they can the
revolutionaries do the same even the
redhead Pirates are rallying around
Shanks near the shoreline everyone just
wants to escape with their lives here as
this terrifying power lights up the sky
a second time well everyone except Luffy
laughing uncontrollably and with tears
in his eyes he protects garp's body from
the falling stones and lashes out at
Blackbeard his incredibly powerful punch
sent Blackbeard flying but the yonko is
caught by Ben auger and brought safely
to the ground once again Luffy starts
chasing down Blackbeard and this brings
him close to her Shanks and a kainu have
passed their fight here Luffy and
Blackbeard Clash once again shaking the
island with their Titanic Powers nearby
Shanks yelled at Luffy to stop fighting
and even a kainu is looking up to the
sky as he moves toward the bridge and
the safety of the red line with the rest
of the Marines but Luffy continues to
Pummel Blackbeard until he is once again
teleported by Van auger out to their
ship waiting offshore luffia Roars in
frustration and starts looking around
for someone else to fight and punch he
starts moving towards Akainu seeking
revenge for Ace just as the beam of
light falls once again but he's halted
as a scream cuts across the battlefields
all the way back at Shore near the
Thousand Sunny a laser blast has fallen
near the gathered straw hats smoke fills
the air and Luffy can see Sanji holding
an unconscious Nami dodging between the
strikes of light as the straw hatku
tries to retreat to the Thousand Sunny
and seeing Nami almost dies suddenly
Luffy snaps out of his battle rage usop
shouts at Luffy to come back and Zorro
leaps down from The Fortress carrying
garb's body Luffy takes one last look
towards the red line and once again
declares war on the world government and
this time he means it he then shares a
really meaningful look with Shanks and
then departs picking up Usopp as they
return to the Thousand Sunny and they
managed to escape however this is far
from the end of the final battle now
that Luffy has even more motivation to
come after the world government he and
the kainu are basically guaranteed to
clash one final time which might well be
the hardest battle for Luffy in the
entire story that's because as we just
saw in this battle the fleet admiral has
one of the most overpowered devil fruits
in one piece in fact all of the Admirals
have ridiculously strong devil fruits
which actually leaves us with another
Super interesting question what do you
think would have happened if instead of
his own devil fruit Luffy had eaten one
of the Admirals fruits and you can watch
that video right here I hope you enjoyed
this thanks for watching